les parcs d'oultremont sont désormais
interdit aux citoyens qui portent un
maillot de bain sur règlement
controversé a été adopté hier soir lors
d'une assemblée mouvementée du conseil
l'interdiction du maillot pour des
raisons de bienséance visera autant les
adultes que les enfants
paul tout en nous en parle cela se
passait à outremont ville dans la ville
où le choc des cultures a atteint hier
de nouveaux sommets depuis plusieurs
semaines les citoyens étaient divisés
par ce nouveau règlement qui interdit le
port du maillot de bain dans tous les
parcs soffin où il ya une piscine
il interdit aussi la baignade dans les
bassins et public des gens comme ceux ci
seront dorénavant passible d'une amende
de 300 dollars ou de deux mois
d'emprisonnement
il ya bien eu quelques grognements 1100
personnes ont signé une pétition qui fut
remise au maire d'outre-manche jérôme
choquette pétition entouré d'un vieux
maillots qui ne servira plus
on a vu aussi une contre pétition de 400
non celle là en faveur du règlement et
appuyer at on dit par la communauté
juive ce qui fut contredit par un jeune
sémites naturiste la discussion a porté
sur la définition du maillot de la
bienséance des bonnes moeurs mais
surtout sur le droit des citoyens qui
n'ont ni corps ni jardin à profiter du
soleil cet avis une question pinceau les
parcs appartiennent aux citoyens
d'outremont n'appartiennent pas à des
devant une maison à des horaires de
maison c'est tout le pain se plaint le
règlement a quand même été adopté mais
un conseiller a précisé que
l'interdiction du maillot ne signifie
pas l'interdiction du bronzage
il semblait sérieux le public a aussi
abri qu'outremont a demandé aux
policiers du poste 32 dollar seul et les
gains qui fréquentent le mont royal
du côté de leur ville ici pas le tout en
à outremont